walk out to this video a new 15 minute
game MC Ewing oil from from Spain so
let's see um yeah come on let's do
something else the bank oh yeah there
he's declined it hmm yeah many lines g6
is one of them tried to get into the
regular banker structures white has some
moves now okay he's some content with
playing a sort of delayed accepted and
now returning this okay so I am I don't
need to recapture it immediately yeah
this b6 line is some pretty good line
for white at some not the refutation
half the bank oh but it's a quite quite
quite playable yeah there's the
reputation of this opening anyway though
some lines are a bit bit tricky for
black okay so what is why term doing
with this b6 move he returns the pawn
and just wants to have a structure we're
not both files are open be sick the be
fine and the a file he basically claims
that this porn on a six is so mostly
obstructing yeah I would like to play
Bishop g4 and get this Bishop exchange
but is maybe his see he asked win a 4
check okay Ally I'd like to learn I'd
like to prevent that I'd like to get
this Bishop exchange this is always a
problem peas in any benoni bank or
whatever structure it does not really
have the useful role why should consider
92 in this position to prevent Bishop g4
yeah and here the question is should i
take or I can also prepare this capture
with the night
one possible movie has a for threatening
a five and of course then I must take
none term after that he might push this
piece away with a five yeah not sure if
I should take with the night or with the
clean probably with the Queen okay just
decided to develop yeah Knight takes
kara I'm not sure I don't really am not
really an expert on this opening with
wider always played a bit differently
and I really never have played the benko
in a series i game I might not like in
tournament chess and blitz I've tried
many things but in tournament chess I
basically never played it at least not
against a good opposition okay yeah he
can consider just castles or maybe a for
a for a five okay
yeah the same porn is really am
obstructing black some flex play here no
doubt what else is possible i mean i'm
thinking i could go a six trying to find
some roller for this bishop yeah come on
I mean it weakens the d6 porn but
where's this Bishop ever going to go at
some I expect him to take and then
Bishop Jake's at least black has some
active pieces I mean it's not so clear
what YP White's pieces are doing the
night really goes to the two in
anticipation to put it on c4 later and
this is why I also was suggesting to
play a for before a4 a5 push the night
back the night c4 and then now after the
capture only six Bishop takes it move
that white probably will consider oh he
doesn't it doesn't take at all that's
surprising ok I'm going to take here
anyway on not where I'm going to take
care anyway that must be right anywho
must be right anyway ok Queen takes
Knight Knight takes Knight takes Queen
takes is just good for black with Bishop
e7 just I just have some super strong
bishops on g7 np7 it's not important
that I have a pawn on d6 yes and but now
now I have a come I have accomplished
something I have the e file open and
this is certainly helping and I'm not so
not bad in terms of development ok
rookie age or something else yeah now
let's just go
it belongs there anyway and the Queen on
b6 is helping to make it difficult for
why to develop the queenside p3 is just
opening up this long diagonal and losses
probably due to 94 at least it loose
materials okay he's getting this Bishop
out of fire okay you know what Bishop f5
has the the normal looking move yeah
come on it's probably also a good one I
mean white maybe can consider g4 here
now maybe really
G for Bishop d7 g five being really
greedy I mean now I need to go to h5
then and you can take it win a bond but
it looks like it looks really ugly it's
not so easy to just to suggest a move
here besides something like g-form you
cannot mix the c1 Bishop rupee one
discovered yeah this is a way to to
prepare so I wonder what about you can I
go see for our Bishop d3 always this is
this not all or just h5 come on not
think too long and ask him what is your
next move you're going to play g4 or
what yeah here g4 I can I can also just
retreat to the seven gh5 Bishop h3 is
just good for black probably yeah he's
he does not have any constructive moves
here it was he needed to take only 6 i'm
pretty sure about that after he six not
94
really tough to suggest something like
rookie one I take and play route eh it
hasn't just not given wide any benefit
yeah let's just do that right now that's
easy a check yeah rookie one that
doesn't look like a brilliant move but I
don't really know what you should do
it's already a very tricky to to to
develop develop your PCM
okay yeah just just that and now it's a
it's all nice but how do I actually win
this game
it's very early actor but i don't i
don't have a direct knockout at least i
don't see it
he does not have many many possibilities
maybe h form and tending 9720 597
immediately ESG form yeah maybe the ship
g5 i take be two heads not on generally
does not have many many many active
ideas he also always must guard the e1
square against this check so quincy to
this rookie one check for example or
queen bee three ugly one check yeah it's
a very very difficult position to play
maybe a for a for a five and rugae for
something like that could be an idea now
it's not very interactive really fit you
must play some move with the nature of
this game yeah so the the simple way to
play is 94 here just hoping that I have
enough pressure with this excellent
bishops on the queenside that's not bad
9075 though is also not bad and that
this looks this looks very clean though
in logical exchanging the knight on f6
which obstructs the g7 bishop against
this knight on c3 which covers the weak
spot on d5 and in general keeps the
Queen side together yeah it's probably
not not a bad move and if he takes rook
checks I'm intending to play look before
just breaking through on the queenside
Knight takes rook takes I mean Bishop b2
is threatening anyway
I'm surprised that he's not taking it
immediately I don't really see any move
besides that when I'm just threatening
to take on c31 what what possible move
should write play besides taking okay I
really didn't think that this masa was
possible but maybe yeah maybe it is
German maybe it is queen bee for a three
hmm that's not entirely convincing a 3
Queen D for Bishop e3
hmm so just maybe create fire in where
where should I go it's not Q&A 70 so
does not make much sense probably ok go
here but yeah okay maybe he's right 94 I
was a possible move
my idea is to play Bishop deform simply
attack on f2
yeah probably there should be three and
then I'm not so sure yeah this is just
giving a tempo isn't it I mean Bishop
before my he master play Bishop e3 em I
thought taking at night g3 threatening
92 check overloading on the night and
III hang so I'm attacking a couple of
things at once guys should be good
should be good I mean black was just far
too active
yeah I'm winning a piece here Queen a
for now it white was busted it was a I
was a complete overload white resigned
yeah I think that really after after he
six white white basically is forced to
take I don't this is what white must do
and then it's just a normal game I think
white has plated somewhat somewhat less
accurately before because this looks a
bit better than what black usually gets
and you know maybe a night the night on
d 2 is just obstructing their own pieces
and might be 393 maybe rookie one I
don't know like that black can consider
d5 he has something like that is at
least very active pieces okay night see
for this this this leads to needs to a
good position already yeah yeah just
just to support it them in the computers
on minus 1.5 already it's very difficult
to even develop your pieces black is so
active computer wants to play the
suggested moved reform yeah really what
should do that I mean just to muddy the
water and now not g 5 which is probably
weakening too much but player then or
something like that just gaining a bit
of space here trying to find computer
suggests a three andrew k2 which is
probably not so bad ok and ok computer
wants to play 94 immediately
check and now it suggests c4 yeah this
was an alternative but I just I think
what I did was was okay yeah i di-did
it's considering black to be completely
winning okay I missed a simple move here
I missed a simple move Bishop d7 here
attacking him White has no no move
freely I'm winning I'm winning the house
here yeah that's easy brilliant this is
the point winning everything ok where
this wins as well ok but with Bishop d7
yeah I just I just didn't see the idea
but ok it's minus minus 3 anyway it's
too much those pieces are all good III
is gone and that's it's completely
uncoordinated in the T Blount that piece
but it didn't really it didn't really
matter much am I think in this opening
white I think white it displays
something like that normally the idea is
that lets say i take here just for
argument's sake and then you get to see
four and you have constant pressure on
d6 so that e-cigs what I played in the
game is not even possible it's something
like let's say here here here here this
is a typical way to play that I think
and maybe it's somewhat better for what
I don't know it's um it's better than
the game I think that what we got in the
game worthy 6 is just okay this was even
better but this type of structure is
probably an okay for black he's somewhat
weakened d6 a six-armed structural
weaknesses but
yeah weaknesses are nice but you need
active pieces and chairs and black has
plenty of active pieces so it should be
at least this and equal position alright
thanks for watching